hey guys Pete here it's gonna be my
thing as you might have missed in Game
of Thrones season seven episode six but
before we get into that I wanted to
mention that the title of the next
episode the season finale episode seven
has dropped and it's pretty exciting
they've named the episode the dragon and
the wolf and I don't know about you guys
but I think that that could probably be
a clue that we're actually going to see
some Rhaegar and Lyanna in the finale
there will be spoilers here so if you
haven't been caught up through season 7
episode 6 you want to stop watching
and with that we'll jump right in the
first thing that you might have missed
in it actually wasn't very hard to miss
I didn't see it until it started going
all over the place after the episode a
bunch of people noticed that the light
on long claws hilt looked like that
there was some kind of animation going
on so people were theorizing that maybe
this was added to show it wake back up
or something like that and there is a
little trick of the light there but it
came out after the fact whenever they
asked the director he basically said no
that was just a trick like it wasn't on
purpose so yeah there was a lot of
conversation about this that it might be
some big clue as to what was going on in
the future of the show but turns out it
was just a happy accident as Bob Ross
used to say the next thing you might
have missed and this was also pretty
easy to miss but in the making of Game
of Thrones website they put out some
more photos so we could see this a
little bit more clearly there was talk
about whether they brought dragon glass
weapons are not sure enough if you look
at this one photo of John with torment
and behind him you can see that torment
has a dragon glass axe but then as I
said they put out this photo that of
this dagger that John has we didn't see
it in the episode as far as I know or at
least he didn't pull it out but they are
strapped with dragon glass just in case
they gettin close with the white Walker
the next thing you might have missed was
a callback of sorts and this went down
in the handing off of Longclaw and
returning it down
when John tried to give lunkov back so
they were talking about jours father
jour because he was the one who gave
John long cloth for saving him but they
also were talking about the slaving
which is a callback to the fact that Ned
was the one who passed the sentence on
Jorah so he would have been the one that
was responsible for killing him if he
had ever been caught so it's a kind of
an interesting comparison John save
Dora's father's life and John's father
or the man who raised him as his son
albeit a bastard son was the one who was
supposed to kill Jorah to carry out
justice for the slaving the next thing
you might have missed was this mountain
I pointed it out that this was the
mountain shaped like an arrowhead from
the hounds vision in the flames and a
couple people had commented in the
trailer breakdown video that this could
be the same mountain that we saw in the
background when the children of the
forest were creating the first white
Walker sure enough it is it looks like
it's from the other side since there's a
waterfall there and things that we can't
see in the winery shot and though it is
the same mountain I don't know that we
were supposed to believe that that
happened right around the back of this
or not they could have used this and
they could have made it for that reason
at this place where this battle went
down but it's also likely that they
could have just since they shoot in
Iceland and it's a nice area there that
they just happen to use the same
location without any real purpose behind
it either way it's very possible that
we'll never know more about it but it is
interesting to look at them both one
with the snow and ice and then the one
before the white walkers were created
where it looks like springtime the next
thing you might have missed was the call
back to Robert's rebellion Jorah is
talking to Thor Samir about the siege of
Pyke it's the last battle of Robert's
rebellion where Balin Greyjoy was beat
down once again in the scene he says he
thought he was the bravest man alive
because he was the first one over the
wall and Thoros points out that he
just really drunk so he was the drunkest
night but maybe not the bravest
something interesting about that that's
where drawer earned his knighthood
that's when he became a knight so it's
important to the rebellion but it's also
important for Dora's origin story if you
will the next thing you might have
missed is that John called Daenerys Dany
we know her from as Danny from in the
books a lot of that name is used a lot
there but she returns and says Danny who
was the last person to call me that
I'm not sure was that my brother Hugh
not the company you want to keep now
what's interesting about that is the
last time that happened in the show it
was when he was pleading with her to
stop Khal Drogo from killing him so
she's saying not the kind of company
want to keep but at the same time she's
remembering her brother's last words so
definitely interesting little callback
there this one we've already talked
about in other videos but it is worth
pointing out in case you didn't watch
those that it was pulled up a couple of
times that Daenerys doesn't believe that
she can have children this of course is
a callback to the first season whenever
Mary mazdoor told her that Khal Drogo
wouldn't be back to himself until the
Sun rose in the West and set in the east
this is tied to a passage in the book
that says that he wouldn't be back until
her womb quickens and she bears a living
child so even though it's not the same
it is brought up that she does honestly
believe that she's not capable of having
an heir another one is one I didn't
notice myself but I did see it in the
camera throw article and Arya happens to
be standing in front of the butcher's
area we can see like sides of beef or
pigs or something butchered behind her
and I know the the Winterfell storyline
is kind of troublesome right now but Kim
pointed out that maybe this is something
to do with it
Arya seems a little bit over the top and
some of these exchanges that they have
and she thought this might be a nod to
the fact that Arya is still holding
meant about songs and not telling the
truth about Micah the butcher's boy and
as we all know that led to lady being
put down by Ned so I don't know if
that's the case or not but it's
something to think about of course we
did get another reference to the wheel
speech that Daenerys gave to Tyrion when
they first met it came up in that same
exchange where Tyrion says that she
can't have a child and that she needs to
think about a line of succession he
points out that she will need to have
someone carry on her legacy because if
she breaks the wheel how will she make
sure it stays broken if not so out of
the last few episodes we've heard this
come up more than once so it may be more
important than just whether or not she
has someone in place to follow in her
footsteps in a similar way that it has
been brought up about her not being able
to have an heir I'm definitely paying
attention to both of those things and
the last thing you might have missed
this is another one that comes directly
from Kim Renfro at the insider because I
don't really notice the stuff with the
Wardrobe she pointed out that Daenerys
is new dress which we also got a much
closer look at in the game of Thrones in
the making a game of Thrones website
that the pattern on the back really kind
of looked like Masseria because of the
coloring now that now they're bigger of
course you can't really see the coloring
as much as you could when the Dragons
were small but his description has
always been cream and gold and the back
of her outfit certainly looks scaly in a
way so I kind of like this connection
another thing to think about
there too is that miss Aryan was the one
that she named after her brother Viserys
before he was put to death he called her
Danny and then John called her Danny in
the episode where Vissarion died so
that's a little bit more of a stretch
but it's kind of interesting at the TEC
same time so alright guys that's it for
the things you might have missed I got a
couple more videos planned for this week
definitely going to look into that idea
of
the dragon in the wolf because I think
that is an awesome name I did a pullover
on the amino app where most people are
agreement that it at least involves
Rhaegar and Lyanna not just John and
Danny so pretty exciting it's definitely
pretty exciting also some other stuff
about the White Walkers and the night
King and maybe one about stuff you might
be missing in this season if you're
paying too much attention to the details
because really I mean people are
starting to get into this rote exercise
of just using two dollar words about how
horrible the writing is and there's some
basis to that but there's still a lot of
interesting stuff here and it's still an
enjoyable show to watch and it's really
just kind of getting tiring when you
hear the same thing over and over like
I'm fine with criticism in this show
there should to be that but it's almost
becoming like a mantra of just repeating
the same things but we have one more
episode two ghosts of all this episode
ever and I'm still excited about it so
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already make sure you turn on
notifications so you know when a new
video comes out follow me on Twitter and
my other social media accounts and
interact with me over there thanks for
watching guys I'll talk to you soon